[MUSIC PLAYING]
CATHERINE RUESCH:
So GMOP stands
for the Graduate Molecular
Biology Outreach Program.
We're a student-run
volunteer group,
and our goal is to bring
science to the community.
KEITH SMITH: We're working
with kids in the local community
and we're showing them
how we can extract DNA.
And we're using
pumpkins as an example.
SHREE TANNETI: There is
science all around us,
so just trying to
find ways to get
people to notice it
and talk about it
and maybe appreciate it.
JARED SAUNDERS: I think that
science can be really fun.
And you can learn
while having fun,
and that's one of
the things at least
I try to keep in mind when you
think of activities when we're
going into an event.
We're brainstorming.
CATHERINE RUESCH:
We target anywhere
from pre-school
children all the way
through actually
senior citizens.
JENNA GASKA: Whether we're
doing special needs day,
or whether we've both
participated and planned
out curriculum, we've
had to really learn
how to be flexible and ready
to improv and figure out
how we can address every
different type of audience we
might be getting.
BETSY HART: So we have
science everywhere
in our everyday
lives, whether it's
having a beer at
the end of the day
or eating some
cheese and crackers.
Both of those processes involve
a lot of science and microbes.
So I think everyone's
a scientist
if they're pairing a different
wine with a different cheese.
So it's fun to have people
understand that and get
inspired by that.
CATHERINE RUESCH: When you see
people have that aha moment
and when they get
that excitement that
comes from seeing some
reaction before their eyes
or when something clicks,
it's just really rewarding.
SHREE TANNETI: I
think any science,
any sort of experimentation,
involves imagination in a way,
right?
You're coming up with an idea
that kind of makes sense,
and you're trying
to address that idea
in the most logical, simplistic
way possible as well.
JENNA GASKA: Going
out into the community
is just making
science accessible
and showing that scientists
can also be accessible.
We're not just locked up
in our labs all the time.
CATHERINE RUESCH:
Fostering an appreciation
and understanding of
the scientific process
is really important
to help people really
trust how science is done
and be able to make informed
decisions.
[MUSIC PLAYING]